it's no secret that gas prices in
America have been exploding upwards but
why has that been happening well the
president of the United States Joe Biden
he recently tweeted an absolutely absurd
message here's the Tweet President Biden
stated my message to the companies
running gas stations and setting prices
at the pump is simple this is a time of
war and Global Peril bring down the
price you are charging at the pump to
reflect the cost you're paying for the
product and do it now now of course this
is an absolutely insane statement coming
from the president of the United States
if we are going to accuse gas companies
of price gouging it simply looks like
they're laying the groundwork to try to
implement price controls at a later date
Jeff Bezos who knows a thing or two
about logistics and Global Supply chains
he stepped in and somewhat of a weird
moment and Jeff Bezos said ouch
inflation is far too important a problem
for the White House to keep making
statements like this it's either
Straight Ahead misdirection or a deep
misunderstanding of basic market
dynamics now regardless of why you think
gas prices are exploding higher it's
very clear that it has reached a level
that is unsustainable for the average
American family to see Jeff Bezos
someone who has spent his entire career
staying out of politics and almost never
commenting to now step in and say you're
either conducting misdirection or you
don't understand basic market dynamics
it's a pretty damning statement Jeff
Bezos maybe he's trying to test the
waters to eventually run for president
or maybe he simply feels like enough is
enough and he has to say something
either way whenever you see the world's
most successful entrepreneurs going
toe-to-toe with presidents of nation
states people begin to pay attention and
right now that's what we need because we
need more people paying attention trying
to understand why is inflation at a
40-year high why is it that Goods like
gasoline or food at home or exploding
upwards and why is it that our
politicians rather than actually taking
action to go ahead and get these prices
down or simply tweeting at companies
telling them to stop price gouging when
we can easily see that these independent
sometimes family-owned gas stations
they're simply trying to make a living
like everyone else
these situations are complex the global
macro environment is impossible to
predict but what we do know is that we
need less complaining and we need more
competing we need free markets and we
need free market solutions to these
problems because right now what we have
is a manipulated Market where central
banks and politicians around the world
continue to intervene
the free market can't work if their
hands are tied behind its back
instead allow the free market to get to
work get the intervention out of the way
and something tells me that we'll get
the corrections the reversions to the
mean that we so desperately seem to need